our discussion of random variables so
far has involved nothing but standard
probability calculations other than
using the PMF notation we have done
nothing new it is now time to introduce
a truly new concept that plays a central
role in probability theory this is the
concept of the expected value or
expectation or mean of a random variable
it is a single number that provides some
kind of summary of a random variable by
telling us what it is on the average let
us motivate with an example you play a
game of chance
over and over let us say a thousand
times each time that you play you win an
amount of money which is a random
variable and that random variable takes
the value 1 with probability to tense
the value of 2 with probability 5 times
the value of 4 with probability 3 over
10 you can plot the PMF of this random
variable it takes values 1 2 & 4 and the
Associated probabilities are 2/10 5/10
and 3/10 how much do you expect to have
at the end of the day well if you
interpret probabilities as frequencies
in a thousand plays you expect to have
about 200 times this outcome to occur
and this outcome about 500 times and
this outcome about three hundred times
so your average gain is expected to be
your total gain which is 1 200 times
plus 2 500 times plus 4
300 times this is your total gain and to
get the average gain you divide by a
thousand and the expression that you get
can also be
written in a simpler form as 1 times 2
tenths plus 2 times 5 tenths plus 4
times 3 tenths so this is what you
expect to get on the average if you keep
playing that game what have we done we
have calculated a certain quantity which
is a sort of average of the random
variable of interest and what we did in
this summation here we took each one of
the possible values of the random
variable each possible value corresponds
to one term in the summation and what
we're adding is the numerical value of
the random variable times the
probability that this particular value
is obtained so when X is equal to 1 we
get one here and then the probability of
a 1 when we add the term corresponding
to x equals to 2 we get little X equal
to 2 and next with the probability that
X is equal to 2 and so on so this is
what we call the expected value of the
random variable X this is the formula
that defines it but it's also important
to always keep in mind the
interpretation of that formula the
expected value of a random variable is
to be interpreted as the average that
you expect to see in a large number of
independent repetitions of the
experiment one small technical caveat if
we're dealing with a random variable
that takes values in a discrete but
infinite set this sum here is going to
be an infinite sum or an infinite series
and there's always a question whether an
infinite series has a well-defined limit
or not in order for it to have a
well-defined limit we all we will be
making the assumption that the
infinite series is as it's called
absolutely convergent namely that if we
replace the axis by their absolute
values so we're adding positive numbers
the sum or non-negative numbers the sum
of those numbers is going to be finite
so this is a technical condition that we
need in order to make sure that this
expected value is a well-defined and
finite quantity let us now calculate the
expected value of a very simple random
variable the Bernoulli random variable
that takes the value 1 with probability
P and the value 0 with probability 1
minus P the expected value consists of
two terms X can take the value 1 this
happens with probability P or it can
take a value of 0 this happens with
probability 1 minus P and therefore the
expected value is just equal to P as a
special case we may consider the
situation where X is the indicator
random variable of a certain event a so
that X is equal to 1 if and only if
event a occurs in this case the
probability that x equals to 1 which is
our parameter P is the same as the
probability that event a occurs and we
have this relation and so with this
correspondence we readily conclude that
the expected value of an indicator
random variable is equal to the
probability of that event let us move
now to the calculation of the expected
value of a uniform random variable let
us consider to keep things simple a
random variable which is uniform on the
set from 0 to n its uniform so the
probability of the value that it can
take are all equal to each other it can
take one of n plus 1 possible values and
so the probability of each one of the
values is 1 over
plus one we want to calculate the
expected value of this random variable
how do we proceed we just recall the
definition of the expectation it's a sum
where we add over all the possible
values and for each one of the values we
multiply by its corresponding
probability so we obtain a summation of
this form we can factor out a factor of
1 over n plus 1 and we are left with 0
plus 1 plus all the way up to N and
perhaps you remember the formula for
summing those numbers and it is n times
n plus 1 over 2 and after doing the
cancellations we obtain a final answer
which is an over 2 incidentally notice
that n over 2 is just the midpoint of
this picture that we have here in this
diagram this is always the case whenever
we have a PMF which is symmetric around
a certain point then the expected value
will be the center of symmetry more
general if you do not have symmetry the
PF the expected value turns out to be
the center of gravity of the PMF if you
think of these bars as having weight
where the weight is proportional to
their height the center of gravity is
the point at which you should put your
finger if you want to balance that
diagram so that it doesn't fall in one
direction or the other and we now close
this segment by providing one more
interpretation of expectations suppose
that we have a class consisting of n
students and that the ID student has a
weight which is some number X I we have
a probabilistic experiment where we pick
one of the students at random and each
student is equally likely to be picked
as any other students
and we're interested in the random
variable X which is the weight of the
student that was selected to keep things
simple we will assume that the x i's are
all distinct and we first find the PMF
of this random variable any particular X
I that is possible is associated to
exactly one student because we assumed
that the x i's are distinct so this
probability would be the probability of
selecting the I student and that
probability is 1 over N and now we can
proceed and calculate the expected value
of the random variable X this random
variable X takes values and the values
that it takes are the x i's and the
particular x i will be associated with a
probability of 1 over N and we're adding
all over all the I's or over all the
students and so this is the expected
value so what we have here is just the
average of the weight of the students in
this class so the expected value in this
particular experiment can be interpreted
as the true average over the entire
population of the students of course
here we're talking about two different
kinds of averages in some sense we're
thinking of expected values as the
average in a large number of repetitions
of experiments but here we have another
interpretation as the average over a
particular population